we first met when you were doing Grey's
Anatomy years ago years ago
yeah and that was during the whole
McSteamy period of your life serious did
that you know what I what I always liked
about you is you never took that
seriously you know there are actors out
there there would be that would lose
their heads over something like that
but you can't take that seriously you'd
be awkward if you did take that
seriously I'm not I mean you know and
the show I'm on now I within five
seasons I'll be 310 pounds with meatball
in one hand and a baguette and the other
sitting at the helm barking orders at
people you really cuz you think that now
they're on the now they're that you
don't to be McSteamy anywhere in the
last ship you can just you can gain you
can get to 300 pounds I'm gonna let it
all go
just every senior eating a thick buttery
chowder and eating a Cosi sandwich I
just don't care anymore right that's
that and I love chowder yeah okay you
posted this picture on Instagram and you
said it was a doctored photo ooh okay
but here's the thing people don't laugh
when they see that with your head on
that body they think yep that's probably
about right if you put my head on that
body suddenly everybody's laughing you
know and so that's why I'm curious like
first of all that was not your body that
was not my body but yeah probably looks
something like that
nothing like that
[Applause]
I honestly I didn't know who that was
that III don't want to know what that
guy did for a living I can I have a
couple of guesses play after that photo
with that could be Andy probably yeah
yeah crowd should get royalties yeah
they do some airbrushing hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos please